Нічний потяг з Берліна на південь Німеччини.
Дванадцятигодинна подорож веде до селища Вільдпольдсрід у передгір'ї Альп.
Воно славиться тим, що є першопрохідцем у переході на "зелену" енергію.
Жодного струму з викопних палив - все надходить лише з відновлюваних джерел енергії.
Все є у природі. Нам не потрібно брати енергію з викопних джерел з-під землі.
Багато чого нам і так дається щодня. Ми просто маємо це використовувати.
Вільдпольдсрід налічує 2600 мешканців.
Селище виробляє у 8 разів більше електроенергії, ніж жителі можуть спожити.
Вся електроенергія генерується не на одному великому заводі,
а децентралізованим способом - і тому є доступною для інших через мережу.
Карта світу - вся у прапорцях.
Делегації з усіх континентів приїздили подивитися на це революційне село.
Зазвичай їх вітає Арно Ценґерле.
Він керує селом уже 23 роки
і від самого початку підтримував перехід на відновлювані джерела енергії.
У 1999 році ми опитали мешканців, яким би вони хотіли бачити село у 2020 році.
Енергія вітру була лише однією з багатьох тем.
92 відсотки відповіли, що вони - "за". Це було сенсаційним результатом.
Люди дуже пишаються тим, що було зроблено у нашому селі.
Великою мірою вони здійснили цей розвиток самі.
За останні два десятиліття жителі села вклали 50 мільйонів євро у триста сонячних батарей,
дев'ять вітрових турбін,
а також у кілька гідроелектричних та комбінованих теплових електростанцій.
Ми хочемо показати, що можна створити регіональну кругову економіку для виробництва
та використання енергії.
Звичайно, це повинно мати економічний сенс.
Отже, якщо це приносить прибуток і ми економимо гроші,
а також робимо щось позитивне для довкілля,
то це подвійна вигода.
Ще один батько "зеленої" революції Вільдпольдсріда - Венделін Айнзідлер.
Він фермер, який почав експериментувати з відновлюваною енергією у 1990-ті.
Доволі швидко він залучився підтримкою своїх односельчан
і створив кооперативну вітроенергетичну ферму.
Кожен, хто живе у громаді, де знаходиться вітряк, може інвестувати.
Чим більше людей приєднуються, тим менша сума інвестицій для кожного.
Нині це п’ять тисяч євро - не більше.
Будь-яка більша сума, і в нас буде вже занадто багато грошей.
Усі постійно запитують, коли ми збираємося побудувати ще одну вітрову турбіну?
Айнзідлер створив чотири біогазові установки на своїй фермі. Тепер вони обігрівають усе село.
Деякі компоненти він сконструював сам.
Джерела енергії - місцеві: тваринні відходи та трав'яний силос з двадцяти навколишніх ферм.
Вони замінюють сімсот тисяч літрів мазуту на рік.
За словами Айнзідлера,
вироблення енергії лише з біомаси недостатньо для переходу на відновлювані джерела енергії
цілої країни - на національному рівні потрібні також сонце, вітер та гідроенергетика.
Якщо продумано поєднувати, то досягти стовідсоткового переходу
на відновлювальну енергетику не так і складно.
Багато хто не вірить, але це правда.
Обсяги чистої енергії, яку ми виробляємо у Вільдпольдсріді,
могли б виробляти й інші громади, райони і федеральні землі.
Виробництво енергії є одним з ключових факторів.
Два інші - це зберігання енергії та розробка розвиненої мережі,
щоб енергію можна було доставляти туди, де це потрібно.
Резервуари з енергією потрібні для періодів, коли немає вітру,
сонце не світить або коли попит вищий, ніж зазвичай.
Компанія Sonnen у Вільдпольдсріді розв’язує ці проблеми.
Вона робить літієво-фосфатні акумулятори,
що в поєднанні з сонячними батареями
дозволяє домочадцям значною мірою стати енергонезалежними.
Ця компанія також управляє системою розподілу електроенергії, яку вона називає Sonnen-Community.
Скажімо, тут хмарно, але у Гамбурзі світить сонце.
Тож, наші клієнти у Гамбурзі мають більш, ніж достатньо енергії.
Їхні батареї повністю заряджені, а надлишок подається в електромережу.
Його можуть використовувати наші клієнти тут.
Вони поєднані через нашу систему Sonnen-Community. Це був перший крок.
Другий - звернутися до операторів мережі та запропонувати їм допомогти стабілізувати мережу.
Приватний шерінг електроенергії,
можливо, одного дня міг би зробити великі комунальні компанії
та їхні величезні електростанції зайвими - якби сотні тисяч інших громад
пішли шляхом Вільдпольдсріда та створили автономні системи генерації та розподілу енергії.
Одне невелике село у Баварії може надихнути людей не лише по цілій країні, а й по цілому світу.